when you were watching last night i know
that's that stamin fight and the
nurmagomedov of that guy that's a good
fight yeah and they say he's not related
they're related let's somebody's lying
these these guys are related yeah you
can't be the same name
yeah and coming into the ufc right there
no they're they're causing somebody's
cause there's something there's
something
somebody definitely has seen somebody
naked in the family you know yeah um
when you watch that fight do you think
that there was anything else that cody
could have done to give himself a chance
or do you think that there was i
seen because i'm uh i'm a [ __ ] nerd
i'm watching i know
all these guys i i watch them fight the
last couple fights and
cody i think
he tried
too hard to wrestle but it's also i
think like he don't it's not like you
need to like to be hit but you know some
guys get hit and they turn up like for
example moreno you can crack the
[ __ ] with a baseball bat and he
will fire back at you
curry salmon get crack in the face and
it's almost like he goes into panic mode
like when he fought jimmy ribera he was
doing well and jimmy rivera landed a big
right hand and he was like oh [ __ ] let
me wrestle you and them it's almost like
fighting is energy you mean like as soon
as i crack you and you're gonna [ __ ] you
it's like okay let's i'm in a real fight
but if you crack somebody and the person
is like
you know what let's not do this you can
feel the energy you can oh a hundred
percent i've been there many times and
i've been here that i'm like
[ __ ] you dude i'm gonna make your mom
cry right now do you think that there
was anything that stamin could have done
to get out to get in a better situation
i think when he hit the single
it was almost like he don't hit the
single to take him down he was more to
don't get hit and that's why probably it
was just so easy to sing the choke and
let's be also honest those russians guys
came pretty prepared
like a necktie right this this
nurmagomedov in a specific have a really
good spinning wheel kick so like he hit
him he started the fight with two hard
ones like the moment somebody did that
to you
i saw he get hurt a little bit and he
kind of like was like [ __ ]
you throw that two to me i'm in your
face i'm like i'm gonna try to take your
hat off right away because it's energy
like if somebody hit you that hard and
you kind of like
don't do nothing about it you let them
get a step ahead let them get a step
ahead
so no i do see what you're saying like i
mean i don't know i mean not you know
like uh
but i know what you're saying like i
always wonder yeah what the energy is
like in there because we just see the
fight you know it's hard to get a an
idea of what that monoi mono like it's a
conditioning like you have to pretend
sometimes do you have to almost like you
have to keep this force field up even if
there's something that hurt do you have
to like keep an energy right there i'm
saying it's okay to be here like we're
not invisible we got
we're not meant for fighting but
once you decide that you're gonna be
your life the moment you get hurt you
gotta either go for a walk you gotta
either
step on the gask but you cannot just try
to avoid the fight because
your opponent will notice that no it's
you can't actually you can see the
colors like like like mortal kombat you
know when you get hit goes down it's
almost like you can sense that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one